Now you've done a lot of work with numbers and most people think that numbers
are what computers are really good at. But truth be told many programmers work
more with text than numbers. In Java the technical term for text is a string.
Why a string? You can think of text being a sequence of individual letters that
are strung together. You have already seen strings. In Java, their enclosed in
quotes and there's some text inside. You've seen string variables, here is one,
it's called name and it's type is string. You've seen a bunch of string methods
and here are a few more. In the interest of learn by doing, go ahead, fire up
BlueJ. And tell me what happens when you call each of these methods, or in the
last case, when you execute this piece of code.